the training program for Navy Seals has
been under increased scrutiny after the
death of a recruit that was back in
February now CBS News has obtained video
showing seal candidates being subjected
to intense tear gas exposure this raises
even more questions about the Navy's
training methods the Commander in charge
of Naval special Warfare has now ordered
an investigation in a message yesterday
to all the seals he urged the men and
the women under his command to create
and enforce a culture of accountability
David Martin has more on that story
recruits for the elite Navy Seals being
hit with tear gas
they've been ordered to sing so they
can't try to ride it out by holding
their breath
exposure to tear gas is a standard part
of SEAL training but the way it's done
here may violate the Navy's own rules
the Admiral in charge of the seals has
ordered an investigation saying the
video raises questions about the
lawfulness of the behavior
if the investigation finds the
instructors deliberately broke the rules
in order to abuse or punish the recruits
they could be charged with a criminal
offense to Sven yort of Duke University
who studies tear gas and its effects the
video looks more like hazing than
training I.E was really shocked and they
were definitely exposed to
concentrations of tear gas that are much
larger than than what what would be safe
the video which the Navy confirms is
authentic was shot last year on San
Clemente Island off California and
obtained by investigative reporter
Matthew Cole author of code over country
tree a recent book about SEAL Team Six I
got this video from some seals students
who were trying to become seals that
felt that the instructors and the the
seals were abusive and uh very careless
with their health most military recruits
have to go through a gas chamber to
learn how to properly Don a face mask
and what happens if they don't
used on the seal recruits appears much
thicker and lasts much longer oh the
rules require the instructors to stay at
least six feet away to avoid the danger
of Burns and to use the gas for no more
than 15 seconds
in this video the gas lasts for more
than a minute
one recruit appears to pass out we
should not injure our recruits that
really serve for us in in this way I
think it doesn't make any sense in
training to do this and could cause
long-term injury video comes to light as
the Navy is already investigating
whether the notoriously tough selection
course has become too brutal even for an
elite unit like the Navy Seals
for CBS mornings David Martin at the
Pentagon
I know you want the recruits to be tough
but I think that's very disturbing look
at that looks just downright abusive to
me I I mean I'll leave it to the
military Community to debate what the
tactics are they know what they're
preparing for what is Extreme versus
what is necessary you know I don't I if
I were a professor I wouldn't be trying
to judge the the tactic part of it he
can talk about the what the effects are
on the body of course they're extensive
you can see from the from the video but
it's just hard for us sitting here to
talk about what's necessary and not yeah
it really is it's difficult I don't
think it's hard I'm looking at it I just
think that was very just but you want I
mean I I want well-trained people I do I
do yeah and that's listen I'm not saying
you have to break somebody but I think
you have to test their limits I think
the question we're asking is how far do
you push somebody and what is the what
regimen of the testing I think the
difference is we're not talking about
sports we're talking about National
Security and defense right and maybe the
standards are different no but again
that's for that Community to debate
amongst themselves should bring a former
recruiter here I would love to